sherry's off today nathan taunted up
with the weather clicker and a beautiful
view from our camera this is uh way down
in the southeast part of town on top of
black mountain in henderson you know you
can see you see a little bit of the
mountain here it's the one with all
those radio antennas on it getting a
little bit of the predawns early light
but you can see the high roller and you
can definitely see resorts world
officially we're at 82 degrees
neighborhoods definitely seeing some
fluctuation here some are dropping a
degree or two some are going back up
70's along the north and the northwest
and along near the southwest lakes good
morning you're at 77 79 for seven hills
and anthem
82 at the air force base 84 is the warm
spot in henderson again we are going to
start turning things around the sun
getting up at 5 24 so just a few minutes
from right now and the temperature is
really going to start rising so if you
got something you wanted to do outdoors
before the heat now is the time checking
nevada and beyond beatty you're at 65
death valley up at 93. ely not too far
from the freezing mark so quite a
contrast from ely up in white pine
county way up to the north down to the
desert of death valley kingman good
morning with your 73 yesterday's high
was 101. we're going to go for 103 this
afternoon that's above normal no threat
to the record high for today's date in
the eight day forecast you'll see some
of the other ones we're going to get a
lot closer we do have this excessive
heat watch starting thursday morning
scheduled to run until sunday and i'm
pretty sure this is going to be upgraded
to an excessive heat warning by the time
we get to thursday basically just trying
to raise awareness and make sure that
you stay safe in the heat despite this
extremely powerful low pressure system
up in the gulf of alaska our area of
high pressure that's building is going
to keep all that storminess away from us
severe storms right now in oklahoma
parts of tennessee moving to the east
also through the eastern great lakes
your 8 day forecast check it out record
high for tomorrow is 112 so we're not
going to be doing that 106 the forecast
high forecast high for thursday is 107.
the current record for thursday's date
is 111.
friday is the date that looks like we're
going to be tying the record high at
108. we'll be close again on saturday
going for another 108 with the record
for saturday's date at 109. bottom line
don't want it to be just a jumble of
numbers the important thing to remember
is this is going to be extremely hot
you know that heat is the number one
weather-related killer in our country
more people die of heat-related illness
than die in tornadoes hurricanes and
floods